سباق مع الصوت يتسارع يوما بعد يوم تتنافس
فيه الدول باسلحه تضرب سرعتها باضعاف سرعه
الصوت اختراق الجدار اللامرئي صاروخ كروز
فرض صوتي اختبرته ايلات المتحده بنجاح هذا
ما اعلنه سلاح الجو الامريكي
الصاروخ تم اطلاقه من قاذفه بي 502 لتفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت بخمسه اضعاف رغم ذلك
يستطيع الصاروخ الفرد الصوتي اسال شحنات
النوويه بدقه عاليه الى الهدف عادا عن
قدرته على التحليق على علو منخفض والمرونه
في تغيير الاتجاه كلها مميزات تجعل من
الصعب اعتراضه ما يرفع امكانيه اصابه
الهدف بنسبه كبيره
التجربه الامريكيه جاءت في اطار برنامج
الولايات المتحده للاسلحه الاسرع من الصوت
والتي قامت بتجارب سابقه على مثل هذه
الصواريخ
لتشتد المنافسه بينها وبين الصيني وروسيا
رغم ان الصاروخ الصيني اخطاء هدفه بضعه
كيلومترات عام 2021
فيما دخلت كوريا الشماليه خط الاسلحه
الخارقه مؤكده انها اجر التجاربها ايضا
تجارب ودفعه الولايات المتحده الى التحذير
من هذا النوع من الاسلحه والتي لا
تلتقطتها اجهزه الاستشعار ما يخلق تهديدا
خاصه مع قدرتها على حمل رؤوس النوويه الى
عمر العربيه